- Good day to just hop on cruise ship and
get acclimated.
Looks like Nina's hungry again.
(restaurant clattering)
You got a full-on plate there.
- I know.
- What is that?
Holy.
(rhythmic music)
It's a video.
- Oh, why you filming a video?
- You going to snore a lot?
- No.
- Okay.
(upbeat, rhythmic music)
What's up, Believe Nation?
Happy Day Two!
(dinging)
It's Day Two in London.
We went to bed at 10 and woke up at four,
so six hours, not that bad.
Sun just came up here in London,
and we are going to do a
little bit of London exploring
and then head off to our cruise ship
to continue our journey.
How you feeling?
- Not bad.
- First we got to find Nina some coffee.
- For you.
- For me?
- And you.
Not just for me, okay?
- I mean, I'll drink some, but--
- Yeah, right.
You the one who's all,
"Let's go get some coffee."
- Nina's a--
- Okay, let's go get some coffee now!
- Nina gets grumpy until
she has her coffee, so we--
- That's not true.
- We're going to go find some.
- That's not true. (Evan laughs)
That's not true.
- Here we go!
(upbeat guitar music)
Sun rising over England, Big Ben
We can't find Nina her Starbucks,
so looks like it's Pret a Manger.
- Oh they have baguettes.
- [Evan] Yeah.
- [Nina] Okay.
- [Evan] Oh wow, see Nina's excited.
Okay, in we go, Pret a Manger.
There it is, our breakfast.
Bagel, chocolate croissant,
and two coffees, mmm.
How's it feel?
You got your coffee.
- Good.
- [ Evan] I'm still finishing my coffee,
but Nina found something.
What did you find, Nina?
She's very excited.
She found her Starbucks.
What are you going to have?
Caramel popcorn!
What?
I wasn't going to get anything, but
I definitely need to try that one.
Starbucks here also has
salad bowls, interesting.
How you feeling Nina?
You found your Starbucks.
- Mm-hmm.
- [Evan] I still have to finish mine.
I saw that smile though.
- Where is my share?
- [Evan] We saw that smile.
♫ Morning coffee
♫ Drink it slow
- [Evan] Do I want you to taste if for me?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] Yeah, yes, I really
want you to taste it for me.
(Evan laughs)
Not like I have an option.
How is it?
Oh it's a lot of, look
at the whipped cream!
- [ Nina] Yeah.
- [Evan] Holy cow.
Is that little pieces of popcorn on top?
- [ Nina] Mm-hmm.
- [Evan] 'Kay, let's give it a shot.
Oh, it's good.
It's lighter than I thought.
They have these dual trays.
I'm trying to figure out if
they actually make them dual,
or they just ripped it in half.
What do you think?
- Ripped it in half.
- [Evan] Ripped it in half?
(PA announcing)
I'm going to say they have it dual,
because I want to discover something new.
So it's, "Wow, look at this dual!
"Wow, Nina!"
We're here at the train station.
Going to get our tickets
and head off to Southampton,
and then we can head up onto our cruise.
Book some dinners there, get set up.
- [ Nina] 'Kay, buy tickets.
- Buy tickets.
Here we go.
(upbeat, rhythmic music)
We're all settled in.
Nina's takin' layers off.
We got a nice table here.
Maybe do some work.
What are you going to do?
- I dunno.
- [Evan] We going to chat?
- Sure.
- [Evan] You going to pass out?
- No.
- [Evan] Nina's probably
going to pass out.
We arrived at Southampton.
It's starting to rain.
So, good day to just hop on a cruise ship
and get acclimated.
Grateful for the awesome day
we had yesterday with no rain.
- [ Nina] Yeah.
- So, we got to find the ship!
Hopefully it doesn't rain too much.
Get onboard!
And come on guys, how cute
is Nina in her hoodie?
(Nina laughs)
How cute is that little
creature in her hoodie, huh?
So cute!
(playful piano music)
We got our cards.
Nina's orange cause she's new.
And there's mine.
Oh, I lost my wife.
Let's go find her.
(crowd chatting)
There she is!
We're gettin' on the boat
and Nina is hustling!
I'm havin' a hard time
keepin' up with her.
Nina is a runner.
The camera's shaking just
trying to catch up with you.
What we need to do is book our specialty
restaurant reservations,
'cause it gets filled up super quick, so
run right to the line.
Alright restaurants are booked.
Next step, we got to get some internet,
get an internet package,
so I can upload these videos
to Christina, my editor,
and also review the videos
coming out next week for you guys.
Still got to do my work,
make sure we're uploading
quality stuff, and then what?
Then we're going to get some food, right?
Ooh, internet package, look at this,
there's nobody here though.
How do we get internet?
Where is the internet?
The manager's not here until two o'clock.
So we're going to just get
some food while we wait.
(upbeat, jazzy music)
Alright, the feasting begins Nina.
Look, see this menu?
(patrons chatting)
- I think I'm feeling gross, I dunno.
- Oh, man!
You're feeling gross,
it's only the first day.
Look at that, all these starters.
Fruit,
and then
entrees,
burgers,
shrimp burger in a pretzel
bun with guacamole?
Wah!
This is exciting.
And dessert.
We get dessert at lunch time Nina.
What do you think?
That doesn't exist in Toronto.
Hey Nina.
- Hi.
- [Evan] How do you feel after
your first meal on the boat?
- It's good.
- Nina had two glasses of wine.
Where are we going?
Ninety what?
- [ Nina] Ninety six oh eight.
- Ninety six, on this side.
I'm feeling super full.
Are you not full?
Oh, you didn't finish your food though.
- [ Nina] Yeah.
- This way, let's go see if it's ready.
See if our room is ready.
We're sneakin' in early.
Alright, here's our room.
Here is our room!
Welcome to 9-6-0-8.
Our home for the next--
- Ten days.
- [Evan] Ten days?
- Kind of scared. (laughs)
Why is this on?
- [Evan] Why are you scared?
- Because the TV is on.
- [Evan] Oh the TV's on.
- [ Nina] Yes.
- [Evan] There ya go.
- [ Nina] Oh we have a champagne too!
- [Evan] We got some champagne.
There's the balcony.
Look at that!
We got a little couch
here for Nina to sleep on.
- No. (Evan laughs)
Maybe for you to sleep on!
- [Evan] At the balcony.
Yeah, alright, happy times!
I don't know why this is on.
- [TV] This drill is how
to familiarize you with--
- [Evan] Oh, the drill.
I don't do the drill.
Nina and I skip the drill.
- [ Nina] Every time.
- [Evan] But, really
we need to have CNN on.
Where's CNN?
How is there no CNN?
No information.
Daily.
Bridge, Safety, BowCam,
Jade TV, ShoreEX, Onboard,
Sky, CNBC, BBC,
Sky News, TV5, Prime.
There's no CNN!
What are we going to watch?
CNBC, maybe.
Wow!
Alright, there we go.
- [ Nina] You know what?
- [Evan] There we go.
- [ Nina] Evan?
- [Evan] What, Nina?
- Alcohol.
- [Evan] Yes.
- [Evan] Okay.
What, you're such an alcoholic!
- Sparkling wine.
- Okay, you already
had two glasses of wine
and it's not even noon yet, okay?
Nina wants me to film the
bathroom to show you guys.
- I want to show you.
- [Evan] Here we go.
Okay, Here's Nina.
- Shower room.
- [Evan] Shower room.
- [ Nina] They have
different door. (door slides)
- [Evan] Uh huh.
- Bathroom!
- [Evan] You're very excited.
- [ Nina] Mirror, bathroom.
- [Evan] Toilet--
- Toilet, this is a different door.
You're very excited about this.
- So you could shower and
I could use the bathroom.
(rhythmic, melodic music)
- [Evan] We got our internet for the week,
but Nina's missing Timo.
- Yeah.
- [Evan] It's only been a day,
maybe two.
What's he doing?
Do you think he misses you?
- Yeah.
- [Evan] You think so?
- Uh huh.
- Okay.
I think so too, a lot, I
think he really misses you.
We're checking out the buffet.
(patrons chatting)
Just to see if there's any
other options that we missed.
We might get a little peckish.
Looks like Nina's hungry again.
You got a full-on plate there.
- I know.
- [Evan] What is that?
Holy. (swooshing)
So--
- [ Nina] Had a nap.
- You napped too.
- Yeah.
- We both passed out.
Woke up, boat was moving,
and now we're going to dinner. (laughs)
We ate, slept, and have go eat again.
Nina's wearin' a new dress.
- They can't see.
- [Evan] Oh, you got a sweater over it.
- I got a sweater over it.
- [Evan] There you go.
- [ Nina] OK.
- This is actually--
- I'm showing the tummy.
- You're showing your tummy.
Well, there's a lot of
food in that tummy, and--
- [ Nina] Yeah. (chuckles)
- There's about to get a
lot more food, in there.
- [ Nina] Yeah.
- Okay?
Let's go eat.
(light, bouncy music)
Nina wants to throw up.
(patrons chatting)
She's feeling very full after
her huge steak and potatoes.
But she still wants to
see the dessert menu.
Yeah?
- No, I probably won't have anything.
I want to go see the desserts.
- [Evan] Uh-huh, alright we'll see.
Finished the dinner, (gasps) feeling full.
How you doin'?
- Very full.
Nina grabbed another
champagne on the way out.
And we're going to go
head up to the 12th floor
to see what the buffet
has to offer! (both laugh)
As soon as we got out,
Nina's like, go upstairs?
(Nina laughs)
Which means go to the
buffet. (walking on stairs)
So we'll see what else Nina orders.
- No, I said I need some warm water.
- Uh huh, let's see if
Nina only has warm water.
Here comes the reality check.
Let's see what happens.
What are we doing, Nina?
- Shows.
- Watch the show.
It's showtime.
(light guitar music)
It's a video.
- Oh, why are you filming a video?
- 'Cause it get--
- Holy Cow,
I thought it was a picture.
- Look how cute you look.
Doesn't Nina look cute?
Leave Nina a comment
if you think she looks cute in the thumbs.
In the thumbs?
- In the thumbs.
- In the comments.
We weren't allowed to
film, copyright stuff.
(loud rock music)
But Nina was freaking out the whole time.
- Yeah, it was just too good.
- Screaming, and--
- Yeah, yeah.
I never freak out at any show,
but this one is the best.
Have to say. (crowd laughing)
(lively guitar music)
- [Evan] Nina got us some more food.
- [ Nina] For Evan.
- [Evan] That's not all for me.
- [ Nina] And we'll have
the wings and spring roll.
The cookies are for you.
- [Evan] Nina got some more alcohol too.
- [ Nina] I was going to get more
but they closed the downstairs--
- I was going to get more?
How many drinks do you need?
We're going to bed!
It's eleven o'clock.
You don't need more drinks.
Well thank you guys for
joining us for day two.
Tomorrow we are off to Holland,
to have another fun day.
- Meet up with a friend.
- We'll see if Nina gets out
of bed in the morning. (laughs)
- Of course I will get out of bed.
- From all the alcohol.
- You're shitty,
I don't sleep much when I have alcohol.
- Alright, thank you guys for watching!
Have an amazing weekend!
We believe in you.
- Continue to believe,
'cause it's important.
Much love,
and whatever your one word is,
we'll see you soon!
Wait, we'll see, 'kay, stop.
We'll see you soon. (Evan laughs)
Bye. (tosses a kiss)
(deep swooshing)
(banging)